what was the quote of the season for you
the quote of the season was when you
feel your own oh it's so hard you forget
that there are other out there she's
feeling her oats the hardest of everyone
[Music]
banjee again and okay wait today make
this okie dookie dookie dookie
everywhere I go people say that it's
spooky and I feel so bad okie-dokie just
spooky I love Ibiza dev spooky Duke but
it just kind of stick some people say
spooky Dookie that's my favorite people
probably don't like it but I do if I had
to live see for my mother I was ready
just at one time when I do no scrubs I
wasn't ready today
[Music]
I want Randy and I committed what was
the quote of the season for you I'm
leaking as I'm speaking I'm currently
losing booty booty booty booty hole only
things she's Devon is Oh booty hoes
others even its opulence chaplains
opulence you earn everything you earn
[Music]
honey I mean we did that Apple and you
own everything I planned for you
everything or was it own everything you
you own you blowin own oh she don't know
I don't need that you earn everything
[Music]
you own everything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]